hey guys I'm Abbi chart welcome to
Abby's kitchen and I'm here as my friend
Abbi Langer how's going so we've been on
Pinterest lately as we do and we've been
finding so many of these bread free
Pinterest sales I think their fails
everyone seems to pin them like crazy
like it's like a disease it's gone
rampant no one want to eat bread I
already had bread is like it's so
important and it's delicious it's the
stop of life yeah you know paralyzed
absolutely everything in moderation yeah
and there are things out there like
we're going to show you that are not
substitutes for bread I don't care what
you say you know it's not going to do it
for me doesn't turn my crank so how
about we see if it turns yours alright
well it turned out like they look like
in pintura so I'm impressed with that
these are called clouds red so what is
it what's it okay so I made these thank
you very much your job they are eggs
like egg whites beaten and then egg yolk
mixed in with cream cheese and cream of
tartar just for the egg wave it's just
in a very feel my tongue leg ass like
dust it wouldn't be very oh it wouldn't
maintain its integrity without language
I don't think I'd eat this as a friend
no God no I wouldn't eat this period how
about them yeah you know I agree
lighter slide those ladders over here
well don't cuz I don't actually want to
eat these at all no why why would you
use zucchini as a bun especially raw
zucchini like zucchini no yeah yeah cook
that take it like that so honestly this
is awkwardest [ __ ] alright ready well I
mean like it's slippery enough I duck it
really soon as I feel a gobbler
well you get some vegetables now but a
table duty on the side
oh nice weird so I was just like two
little cocktails
little meatball yeah and then oh here's
some Roger Taney I think I'll just have
some type of you act with a dip but yeah
what the normal person would do yeah
what's a good so I know pretty quickly -
yeah oh my god
so I had to you got a really this is a
double hander right here I'm going to
Columbia with this seriously totally
good so guys a cucumber is not a bun
it's not a submarine it's dripping all
no no one likes a boy Edwige but yeah I
mean how could it not be a watery
sandwich when you're gone bun is just
water it's yeah it's water what are you
putting this so I got some nice deli
meat on some some processed cheese and
some mayonnaise because that's what our
friends on Pinterest had suggested as
ultimate combination yeah I'm really
excited for lunch
you know what this is the most benign
thing we've eaten all day
oh no that's pretty sad let's look at
this except that it's dripping
mayonnaise in water on the table which
it up is revolting but this is another
example of something you can totally
become strong just eat the mean cheese
and then eat the cucumber separately
yeah like it's really not the hurt I
mean I'm happy to just eat a little bit
of this goodness yeah yeah we need that
after what we just ate Marissa this one
was a little a little ode to our last
video the reddit thread on the keto diet
this is also a keto friendly recipe here
actually they all really fail really are
but this is basic cream cheese pickles
and wrapped in salami and since it
appeals I have a fat coating on the top
of my mouth immediately it's so much
green chilli - I just don't want you on
the far left is no for a while no you
don't you should spit it out no don't do
this it's gross it's just I can't
imagine having a snack oh I'm gonna have
a snack
how about a block of cream cheese and
some process me it's not a snack that's
yeah so horrified this is the epitome of
process yeah it's all processed meat
with politicals
and well I mean ultra-processed lay on
this cheese it's like a fat home it's a
fat bomb but a very salt on
unpleasurable lemony for God's sake I
was so happily fearless please these
pieces of bread yeah wait get any loud
bread yeah
wait really we suggested this so I know
but you know I mean I have a little desk
office every little desperate this way
okay so let's see what this cloud by
though I mean I like myself
you can productive role escrows that
bread is broke it's gross
it also some cheese and I like some
cream cheese I mean I know we're Jewish
we're basically religiously obliged to
enjoy our cream cheese and our bake and
our bagels but get the goddamn battles
oh hell no got me a bag oh my god like
this is this is bad this is just that
awful no yeah well obviously the slice
yes it has a salami and safety knot
salami ah so are we here
well if you enjoy this torture session
be sure to give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below
but some of the crazy things that you've
seen on pagers that you want to try
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time at Hobby
station
[Music]